[Musique]
qui me gêne c'est à billiers dans une
équipe c'est un mec qui apporte beaucoup
par son charisme par son entrain d'en et
sa détermination sur sur le tapis c'est
quelqu'un que j'ai côtoyés très tôt on
était en étant club ensemble on a gagné
pas mal de choses ensemble et c'est vrai
qu'en équipe il répond toujours présent
c'est un fou il est là quand on a besoin
de lui
[Musique]
alors guillaume vous êtes rentrée ce
lundi 2 août de tokyo vous êtes médaille
d'or du judo et par équipes mixtes
qu'est ce que ça représente pour vous ce
titre olympique c'est je pense que c'est
l'accomplissement d'une carrière rêve de
gosse qui se réalise même si eux
réalisme encore aujourd'hui on
on a vécu des moments
des moments historiques voilà sur sur
cette journée par équipes
on est les premiers à remporter
cette édition bloquer ces nouveaux sites
le nouveau n à jamais les premiers au
japon en battant déjà posé en finale
donc c'est que des émotions
extraordinaires et voilà là on prend le
temps de profiter en arrière va réaliser
petit à petit ce qui nous arrive c'est
remporter vos deux combats c'était dur
sur le tatami bien sûr chaque combat est
compliqué mais on sait que chaque point
compte chaque point est important
et tous autant qu'on est dans l'équipe
on l'a peu tout le monde a su être
décisif quand il le fallait
et voilà c'est ce qui fait que
que ça a déroulé sur la fin de journée
on a on a été accroché par les
israéliens au premier tour je pense que
voilà c'était un élément déclencheur est
là tout a basculé
derrière ça déroule c'est très sexy on
voit tous ces français rassembler les
membres de votre club à sartrouville le
vice président du club
ça fait plaisir ça doit faire chaud au
coeur bien sûr mais de toute façon ça
fait déjà longtemps que je sent
l'engouement qui est derrière moi je
sois au club de sartrouville même la
ville tous les a retrouvés loi change
vraiment qu'il ya un élan fédéral
derrière moi hé hé oui je pense que il
ya un moment donné où ç'a dû me pousser
sur cette olympiade
un mot sur le club de sartrouville et
c'est ça représente pour vous ce que ça
fait plus d'un an maintenant que vous y
êtes s'appelle donc je suis au club et
que tout se passe bien
ils m'ont accordé leur confiance et ils
me font ressentir chaque jour ils me
soutiennent tout le temps
chaque fois que j'en déplacement en
stage en compétition ils sont toujours
derrière moi et voilà pour une année
charnière comme celle ci avec ses jeux
olympiques au bout c c'était quelque
chose d'important pour moi et voilà je
suis arrivé à tokyo dans des conditions
parfaites
puis vous la rendez bien j'espère que
voilà je leur rends bien héberger plus
honneur au club que j'ai vu honneur à la
ville et qu' il y aura encore de belles
heures de gloire pour le co ce jeu de
guillaume dans trois ans vous aurez 37
ans ce sera les jeux olympiques de paris
vous serez toujours là sur le tatami à
paris ça je peux pas le jeu peut pas le
prédire
maintenant j'ai encore envie je me fait
encore plaisir le corps ça va ça va
encore plus ou moins non non je me sens
encore très bien et j'ai encore envie de
me faire plaisir sur le tapis donc si je
peux pousser jusqu'à paris je me serai
jusqu à paris maintenant il ya il ya
beaucoup de jeunes qui est voilà qui
équipera pas au portillon donc il faudra
qu'ils vont répondre présents sur cette
course sur cette nouvelle course elle
implique
c'est énorme c'est inespéré c'est tout
ce qu'on veut quand on est un club de
banlieue et qu'on travaille depuis des
années des années une succession
d'entraîneur et de président et d'avoir
aujourd'hui un athlète qui va aux jo
c'est déjà fabuleux est d'abord un
athlète qui ramène une médaille d'or
c'est quelque chose de fabuleux pour le
club pour la ville et pour tout le
milieu associatif de la ville
c'est comme si c'était un peu notre
professeur il nous donne des conseils et
nous apprend des techniques avec le
mercredi avec les autres athlètes de
haut niveau il vient il nous apprend
plein de choses c'est c'est super
flattant témoin louvre à paris ouais
j'espère qu'il sera là et qui veut
encore gagné beaucoup de médailles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]